d'avoir une dalle et 30 secondes oui
trente secondes parce que oui justin
voulait je crois que vous avez raison
parce que bon on a un petit truc on à la
première télé maintenant oui et non
c'est encore pire que çà mais j'en ai
fait je remarque maintenant c'est à dire
que ouais j'en marque money c'est vrai
c'est guillaume jean mermoz et aussi ses
membres et ouais j'ai énormément de
respect pour lui et je l'embrassais qui
vous d'aborder très grand will avait il
annoncé plus loin de vous pour lancer
une année magnifique à ce sujet allant
voir la première télé de guillaume
genton je me permets de prendre 10
secondes pour vous remercier parce que
grâce à vous chaque semaine la en ce
moment chaque soir je réalise mon rêve
une partie de mon rêve et c'est grâce à
vous donc merci beaucoup et lundi que
vous voyez ma semaine et la co star très
sobre mais où il ya un truc tu ne le
doit qu'à toi non victimes on verra ça
vous sur cette voie là c'est grâce à
vous je remercie toute l'équipe et
surtout lundi que vous voyez ma tête et
mes co star un peu chelou chaque semaine
mais derrière il ya une équipe il ya un
cap ou bep qui a pas mal d'idées mais on
revient du producteur à des logiques de
la vie lauriane fabien de l'être tout
est bon à bron
voilà donc c'est toute une équipe qui
bosse der lundi que ça demande beaucoup
de travail donc je voulais vraiment leur
faire un gros big up
[Applaudissements]
la firme en terre
conques à sébastien bach de risques en
cas lui neil stein évidemment toute la
direction un stade comble merci tu peux
avoir un petit billet en plus à la télé
de guillaume genton regarder parce que
il m'a bien cherrier ou semaine c'est ma
part j'en sais sur ma chaîne étudiante
je crois la télé est à vous et sans
tabous soyez les bienvenus dans libre
antenne aujourd'hui on va s'intéresser
un thème qui concerne beaucoup de jeunes
à savoir les mutuelles étudiantes alors
couvre-t-elle suffisamment leurs
affiliés pourquoi ont-elles fait parfois
l'objet de scandales dans l'actualité
pour en parler je reçois beat them all
mb bonjour alors juste avant de rentrer
dans le vif du débat est-ce qu'on peut
rappeler qu est ce que c'est qu'une
mutuelle étudiante à lui je pense comme
moi et je pense que tu devrais sais pas
comment ça fait deux semaines que je te
dis de faire cette coulée regard sam est
un conte écoute moi bonne chance avec un
lacet laurent delahousse de we show si
vous étiez sur une île déserte
vous n'êtes plus avec votre mac vous
devez partir avec un chroniqueur partent
avec qui rien car manger tous les permis
c'est bien d'un mensuel sachant que
sucré nature aussi il a déjà viré
c'est faire livrer des biens pernikoff à
carreaux pardon je vois bien pernikoff
ah d'accord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]